in our area they had a thing called ligo
ligo laser interferometer gravitational
Observatory there's only two of them in
the United States in Louisiana and I
visited them in Louisiana and up in
Oregon or Washington Washington yeah so
that was another thing in our area so
you know there was by the way just to be
clear that is discovering colliding
black holes in other galaxies Across the
Universe damn it's a new kind of
telescope and you got it there in your
home state I knew they were up to
something all we heard was that they had
gravity Hunters out there that's that's
a that's a good way that's a poetic way
to put it so that's what we heard and so
there'd be people like if you saw
somebody that could dance real good
you'd say they were like one of those
gravity babies or whatever or sometimes
people would have parties and people
would say oh you know we're going to get
so and they would live near there by the
in Livingston Parish Louisiana where
that ligo Center is and they'd say we're
going to get so [__] up we can't even
feel the gravity yeah yeah there it is
yeah wow zoom in on that that's crazy
yeah yeah so what's going on there if if
your listeners have access to this if
you were so those are two long tubes and
they send a beam of light from that
Central Building
simultaneously the full length of both
tubes and then there are mirrors at the
end of those two both tubes and it
reflects back and they recombine the
light
and if the light recombines perfectly
then nothing happened between those two
uh Reflections but if a gravitational
wave washes over Earth and goes through
this facility one of those beams will be
slightly delayed compared to the other
they're doing that out there and they
can measure it I know people that can't
read out there they delay and so they're
looking for a variation in a fraction of
the diameter of a proton
and that is a completely evacuated tube
that goes up and back uh so tell me this
so say they find a say say there's some
variation what does that tell them that
there's some pole of course it tells you
that the thing actually happened
Einstein predicted the existence of
gravitational waves this discovered them
8 60 70 years later wow okay no no more
than that this was 2000 when was that uh
this this Century Einstein made the
prediction in in 1916. so you're talking
basically 100 Years A Century there's a
prediction and then a discovery and this
is this is ground truth that our ideas
actually match objective reality okay
and you want to say well how does that
put food on your plate it doesn't but in
advanced technology in a way that will
surely have applications later on
Einstein wrote down the first equation
in a paper called on the stimulated
emission of radiation obscure quantum
physics paper in the 1920s okay late
teens and why are you doing that you're
a smart guy why don't you help put food
on people's plates wanna do you know
what that's the foundation of the laser
which would not be built until the 1950s
and and lasers back then were like cost
tens of thousands of dollars in their
room size now they're impulse items at
at Walmart yeah and for laser pointers
right oh yeah but lasers are now you
know barcode now photos can do it but in
their day barcode reading laser surgery
LASIK surgery for your eyes
um laser Cosmetics removal so whoa
lasers you put a laser on anything on
anything and do you think Einstein's
saying yes we're gonna have LASIK
surgery with this equation that I wrote
now nobody's thinking that so the people
say why are we doing this with smart
people when the smart people could be
solving the homeless problem because we
don't know what the future is you don't
know what the future is somebody might
invent a laser that makes home homeless
people happy okay
so you don't know what about this though
so say that thing picks up some sort of
gravitational wave what does it mean it
means that there's a black hole that's
kind of sucking on earth a little bit no
it meant two black holes collided and
the Collision is quite catastrophic and
it sends a ripple
it's it's like tossing a pebble in a
pond okay and you see the Ripple go out
in all directions except the pond
surface is only two it's flat in space
this is a ripple that goes through full
three dimensions of space and it's
moving at the speed of light and it
washes over Earth at the speed of light
and by the way remember I said make sure
you don't think something that's true
that's not you feel what you want to be
true rather than what is true suppose
you're just a mischievous graduate
student and you're in that facility say
I want to I'm going to tweak this and
all everyone else is going to think they
actually discovered something okay yeah
yeah or I suppose you did suppose you
you're diabolical you just said pranks
oh I would do that either uh you're just
a prankster all right we have built-in
protections against that oh damn
we have another one they got a ring
camera we have an entire other ligo
in Washington oh making sure yes okay so
you would have to coordinate
prankster yeah to do it at the exact
moment okay whatever now
okay
they both made the measurement but
separated by a fraction of a second
just what you'd expect if the wave came
from One Direction continues to wash
over Earth and goes across and comes out
Seattle on the other side of the Earth
okay that 1500 miles whatever that
distance is takes like time to do that
they were able to measure that precisely
it was good in Louisiana we had primate
testing facility where they created the
polio vaccine was in our town so Tulane
University didn't know that it's just a
primate testing facility in St Tammany
Parish Louisiana and I remember
one time a bunch of the monkeys had
gotten out right and they came and got
us out of YMCA summer camps the police
did the tallest kids to help them and so
we're out there by like the monkeys on
the trees and you got to reach for him
or how are you going to get them the
monkeys are just out yeah and they
wanted like a chain of people I guess oh
okay and so uh By the way when the
monkeys get out there's no that's that's
a scary fact right oh in hindsight
knowing now what I know about monkeys
and chimpanzees I think it was a bad
idea oh okay but at the time we didn't
know so you know it was a smaller town
then and so we're out there just
wrangling chimps out by this Kenny
Rogers Roasters he used to have like a
Kenny Rogers had a a chicken
establishment for a while and they had
like kind of rotisserie chicken it's
pretty good monkeys are running
hey skate monkeys achieved Consciousness
intelligence I wouldn't be shocked
that's about the Planet of the Apes [__]
going on I would not be shocked I've
seen some people there that work at some
of the gas stations definitely they have
a banana for lunch I'll say that dude
there's some interesting folks there you
know chimpanzees peel the banana from
the bottom did you know that yeah yeah
you know what my friend does he breaks
the banana in half like if it's if it's
unripe yeah that'll work yes that's true
otherwise you got some mashed banana
right there
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one